in Northern California one organization
helping wildfire victims will serve
Thanksgiving dinner for thousands of
displaced people today at least 83
people died in the campfire and more
than 560 others are still missing
survivors living in a tent city could be
hit by six to eight inches of rain
expected over the next few days Carter
Evans is in Paradise California the town
nearly wiped out by the fire Carter good
morning good morning it's already a
rainy Thanksgiving here for so many that
are left homeless and the thousands of
firefighters that are still on the
frontline the big concern right now is
that the rain and possibly mud flows
could wash away human remains and also
turn this ash into a thick paste that is
very hard to search on the fire chart
hillsides near Paradise emergency crews
are rushing to protect what's left of
the town from mud and debris crews spent
Wednesday laying down more than a mile
of these straw filled tubes designed to
control runoff what's the concern the
biggest concern especially up in
Paradise is that a storm is going to
bring down trees anyway so now after the
fire has gone through the trees are even
more weakened the rain is making life
even more difficult for evacuees
hundreds are spending Thanksgiving in a
makeshift camp outside of a local
Walmart the store is asking them to
leave citing health and safety concerns
and it's working with local authorities
to increase capacity it approved
shelters but for some getting to the
more distant shelters is difficult kami
Machado lost not only her home but also
her car we didn't have one until last
night that's why we didn't go to a
shelter we have a car to get out to go
where we needed to go
a disaster relief organization world
central kitchen hopes to feed
Thanksgiving dinner to 2500 evacuees at
a shelter later today so the biggest
thing for me is creating an experience
for people with food that that brings
them together and allows them to forget
about some things for a while that's not
an easy task for Machado but she says
even after losing everything she still
has hope
anyone from Paradis anyone from Butte
County anyone from the ridge where
Phoenix is its rise from these ashes
that's what I'm gonna do it's been
looking at now also attending this
Thanksgiving dinner for evacuees will be
some of the 2000 firefighters who still
remain here but they'll be here to serve
dinner just one more way they say to
give back to this community flat our
hearts certainly go out to our fellow
Americans there in California Carter and
all those firefighters who've been on
the front lines thank you